you guys have become what i would argue
is the go-to source for uh people to
find out about
politics news
breaking news etc people are done
listening to cnn msnbc fox news all
these people are catering to the 60 and
up crowd
what's the goal here like what what do
you want breaking points to become and
how do you think about like the journey
that you guys are on
it's a great question man you know to me
all we do is great questions here just
to be clear that's all we do is good
questions all we do is great questions
so go ahead
right
that's always a tick right as an
interviewer i always notice that people
always say that so now i find myself in
the same thing but look here's what it
is is that too many people have branded
themselves outside of the mainstream i
don't think that that's the correct
branding what it or even the correct
mission the mission is to replace the
mainstream that's why i love what you
guys do that's why i ultimately love and
have i'll have a big the
the message of bitcoin and a lot of the
crypto community which resonates with me
the most is not necessarily the
antagonism although i think antagonism
is important it's simply to replace the
existing centers of power i can see with
my own eyes what's happening with cnn
and the new york times what you know
msnbc all these bs streaming services
that they're launching i can't wait i
want them to fail i want them to
actually compete in the free market this
is what's happening right now is that
the internet freed all of us from the
chains of a rigged system facts and i
want to explain this to people which is
that these cable places they don't make
any money from actually your eyeballs
they make money because cox
communications and comcast pays them to
be a part of the cable bundle now old
people like live news and look i gotta
say like it is valuable right turn the
tv on on january 6th turn the tv on
during these like blm riots turn the tv
on during 9 11. live news is crazy but
the problem is it's not actually
valuable what 99.9 of the time so they
fill it with bs and this has gone to the
heads of a lot of the idiots here in
washington who think that people
actually want to watch them but it was
rigged it was a completely rigged game
and so now out here in the youtube
ecosystem in the internet where you
actually have to compete for eyeballs
and attention
nobody cares
absolutely no one and this is what the
new mainstream is gonna be for people
our age for people who are younger i
have a big gen z fan base as well they
don't care about cnn like i am the news
to those people and i think that's the
way it should be i should have to
compete actually compete for not only
for your attention but to try and inform
you on a level playing field i think
that you're hitting on a number of
points here first is uh they're all
going to close networks you have to be
on cable to watch them right if you
don't watch it in in the moment that
you're pretty much not going to see a
majority of the content uh all the
issues that we know go on um and when
you go to the open network right open
networks when people in bitcoin
understand open networks win over closed
and it's the same thing here in the
media uh you're uh very interesting
because you live in washington dc you're
very plugged into what's going on there
how stupid are these people like like
yeah like
and just so everyone understands right
my brothers and i are very clear like
i'm an independent i think that both
sides are you know absolutely ridiculous
at the extremes i frankly think most
people uh my age and younger are just
getting to the point where they're just
like look enough is enough this is
absurd like there's real things at play
here and all of this kind of pull uh
political divisiveness et cetera is
really stupid but like you talk to a lot
of these people on a daily basis you
don't need to give me names but like are
they actually dumb or are they like so
smart that they know what they're doing
and they're just kind of leading the
american public into like the
slaughterhouse so no 99.5
are just complete and utter morons and
it's it's really important to understand
the pipeline through which that these
people succeed which is that you are in
the district you're a lawyer the way
that you want usually a lawyer or some
like prominent businessman then you
court the party elites all you have to
do is win the primary okay that's it the
most of these elections something like
90 something percent are not competitive
they're decided whether you have an r or
a d next to your name so the only thing
that matters is the primary itself so
you have to cater to let's say five to
seven percent of the actual population
of your district in order to represent
the 99. it's actually not all that
competitive and it's mostly rigged by
either the party elites or you know you
can have a stupid contest in terms of uh
appealing to those five to seven percent
and then basically winning once you get
here once you get here you have zero
incentive to inform yourself about the
broader world at all all of these people
either spend their time fundraising they
don't actually spend that time engaging
with the news or the broader public i
mean i frankly think the crypto
community found this out the hard way uh
during all of the regulation during the
infrastructure bill is and i've been
telling people you know pomp you know i
met miami and i was telling you a little
bit about this which is i was like you
got to be here
you got to shove it in their face and
say hey we matter we're real this is
where the future is because they'll just
wake up one day decide that they need
money for some bs part of their bill and
then they'll tax the [ __ ] out of you and
they'll do it either they'll tax it or
they'll regulate it in a way that they
don't understand they have no actual
expertise they don't actually seek
knowledge on anything almost all of them
are concerned with becoming famous or
becoming and winning their primary
that's it or becoming rich curiosity
curiosity is not rewarded in washington
in fact it's punished it's dramatically
punished stepping outside of your box